hey youtubers is charlie so this is
going to be my flash arrow preview for
comic-con their bait they're basically
doing the big DC super panel so they'll
have legends of tomorrow and Supergirl
stuff there too I've already done that
legends of tomorrow video arrow in the
flash are a little bit different and
just they have a lot more to show off
there's a bunch of stuff that we've
learned about the flash in the last
couple of weeks and they're just like so
much more material for air on the flash
than there is for the new shows just
just because they haven't aired yet
there's no episodes Supergirl pilot
notwithstanding of course but just to
start with the flash there's a couple
characters that I've already done videos
for a couple new characters that we've
learned about and obviously we know
about hot girl and that legends of
tomorrow characters but they said that
they're also bringing on a whole bunch
of new people so don't expect them to
recycle too many villains from last
season I mean will see the Rogues like
you can't have a season to the flash
without the Rogues but just off the top
there's the mystery big bad that we're
supposedly gonna learn about in the
first episode I don't think they're
gonna reveal that at comic-con I think
they'll save the surprise for that first
episode but we do know about Caitlin
snow killer frost that's gonna be
happening at some point we know about
dr. alchemy and we know about mirror
master I think dr. alchemy is the only
one that I haven't done a separate video
for he's an interesting character he's a
little bit different from the rest of
the Rogues he hates the out of the
reverse-flash and yes Tom Cavanagh is
coming back as a series regular but you
know obviously because of what happened
in the finale it's not going to be as
the exact same character just one of the
advantages of having an amazing actor
and not being bound by time and space
and in terms of storytelling seriously
it's like Barry traveled into the
untempered schism from Doctor Who I feel
like now that Rory is on legends of
tomorrow they're just going to be so
much doctor who overlapping that you
guys just keep your eyes peeled for
Easter eggs it helps a lot that the
showrunner Andrew Kreisberg is like the
biggest Doctor Who fan ever I have had
the opportunity to shake his hand but
I've never had the opportunity to ask
him which doctor is his favorite
speaking which I owe a debt of gratitude
to the people at Warner Brothers because
I have a scheduling conflict Saturday
night it was looking like I wasn't going
to make it to that Warner Brothers panel
like that the big super panel I was
freaking out a little bit Warner
Brothers gave me an invite to like a
special room where I can see it there so
no worries I'll at least be able to see
it hopefully I'll be able to record it
too I'll still be live-tweeting no
matter what and if they drop any footage
I'll do videos for that too so
hopefully they'll be the panel and then
any trailers that they drop originally
it was a bit of a bummer you know
because Comic Con is so early this year
they weren't gonna have any footage
because they weren't supposed to start
shooting till next week but the producer
said that yesterday was the first day of
production so they might have like a
little bit of something I don't think
all the actors Ron said so it might just
be something special but hopefully you
guys watch both the arrow and flash last
year she got a sense for what the
crossovers were like imagine that times
ten like there's going to be so much
more crossover this year Grant Gustin
said that their big bad the big villain
of the season is going to cross over
with legends of tomorrow so I think the
same thing is going to happen with arrow
we know the arrow villain is Damien dark
that's already been confirmed by the
producers so what they might do is
reveal the actor that's playing him
because if everyone already knows who
the character is then you might as well
reveal who is gonna play them because
they probably cast that person usually
this time of the year is when they
announce which actors they've cast and
what roles unless it's like a secret
role because there has not been a leak
on the flash in terms of like who the
big bad is going to be I think they're
just going to hold that back so that
it's a bigger surprise and even though
they might not have like a ton of big
footage what they can do is reveal what
some of the costumes are going to look
like what some of the sets are going to
look like they can still show off a ton
of stuff the real long shot like the big
hope is that they'll show off what hot
girls costume is going to look like they
scanned her whole body so part of it is
going to be CG i'm guessing part of the
helmet and part of the wings if you
remember Michael Shanks from Stargate he
played Hawkman on Smallville his helmet
just looked like a little bit weird so
don't expect it to look that crazy it'll
probably a little more toned down a
little more practical what I really want
to see is her flying around swinging
that mace Hawkgirl is primarily a
legends of tomorrow character but
because arrow and the flash have like a
full half season before legends of
tomorrow starts they're just going to
use those to create some context meaning
that we'll probably see Hawkgirl on
arrow in the flash in the first half of
the season I actually just found out
that legends of tomorrow doesn't start
shooting for a little while air on the
flash though they'll be full steam ahead
starting next week they're in production
this week like I said but I guess I
think next week is when all the actors
were on set the big news about arrow I
know everyone's wondering what's going
on with Oliver because he's off in Coast
City you know everyone wants to see
green lantern on top of that he said
he's done
the arrow name it's completely trashed
he's never gonna use it again but he did
say that he is still a vigilante he was
actually responding to someone else's
question but he just he self-identifies
as a vigilante so that should tell you
what he's going to be doing even if he's
not wearing the arrow costume or using
the arrow name I think what we'll see
you for most of the first half of the
season is just all of our kicking butt
in his street clothes team arrow kind of
scattered at the end of last season
don't be surprised though if they all
come back together before the mid-season
finale usually what it takes for
something like that to happen to bring
everyone back together is the big bad
that's that's like a very midseason
finale WTF moment but there will still
be the episode 8 flare Oh episode like
where arrow in the flesh were like the
entire main cast go on each other shows
so they'll at least be together for that
episode we don't know as much about the
new characters coming two arrows we do
about the new characters coming to the
flash so just to expect them to tease a
couple comic book characters on arrow
but here's my big question for you guys
what do you want to see them do at this
panel do you want them to show off some
footage that they've already shot you
know hopefully that will happen or do
you really want to find out who is
playing Damien dark I'm still of the
belief there's there's this wide rumor
going around that he might end up being
Felicity's secret father if you remember
he joined the league of assassins with
Ray Shaw goal before Rochelle Goyle
became the next ratio like way way way
back when they joined they had to leave
their past life behind so that would
explain why Felicity's father was never
around let me know if you wanted to go
down that way it'd just be a really
interesting way to pull Felicity into
the action in a way that she wasn't part
of it during season 3 I feel like she
got sidelined a lot even Emily BETT
Rickards like the actress said that she
didn't want to cry anymore like she
spent most of last season crying she's
like I do not want Felicity to cry
anymore but more Guggenheim did say that
they they would address the fact that
felicity is now the CEO of Palmer Tech
like she signed that document they said
they'd follow up on that so technically
felicity is now Oliver's boss so I'm
sure they'll have some fun with that
Thea gonna be kicking a ton of but I
know a lot of you are asking about her
costume they'll probably show it off
again at the comic-con panel but I think
they're just going to stick with that
red one like they spent a ton of money
making it in terms of weapons I'm just
I'm hoping to see her use a sword
every once in a while but she's probably
gonna try and be not lethal so she's
probably going to end up using a bow
most of the time Diggle is the big
question though like will he start
wearing a mask and using a secret
identity Oliver suggested to him at the
end of the season that he start using a
protective face covering to hide his
identity and everyone wants them to get
a Green Lantern ring but I do not think
that they're ready for that in the arrow
verse that would be like a great flera
episode where everybody gets a Green
Lantern ring the last time they did that
in the comics was the war of light were
like Superman like every single DC hero
got a lantern ring baked based on their
alignment so just a reminder all the
arrow flash legends of tomorrow
Supergirl all that stuff is happening
Saturday night so you should expect my
videos for that to post Sunday morning
because it's gonna be like really late
when we get out of that be sure to
subscribe to get everything and if you
want to follow me on Twitter and
Facebook I will be live tweeting the
panel you can find links for that in the
description below it's gonna be really
fun weekend it's going to be crazy
there'll be a ton of videos so just be
sure to check back every once in a while
I've started making a special comic-con
playlist you can click here for all the
videos in that I may have a couple in
there right now I've only posted a
couple so far but you can also click
here to learn all about the history of
killer frost in the comics thank you so
much watching everybody let's high five
I'll see you guys tomorrow